[Music]
you said you spent your childhood most
of your childhood eating cabbage that's
very common well you know kids always
have to eat vegetables it's healthy
right right it's to do a lot of our
dishes are based on cabbage and other
vegetables and the tricks to get you to
eat like because I know with our kids
I'm always saying if you eat that you'll
get really strong what do they say to
you get cab exactly so basically for us
it was well for girls especially they
say that if you´d cabbage you you know
you you grow you grow hands oh I see you
you become you're your breasts will grow
large yeah right trust me we just had a
guest out here talking about you know
eating mushroom yeah go for it
they would literally tell women that
little girls and so of course every girl
wants it well I I hope I don't know well
yeah I wanted it and and and I kept
eating and eating cabbage I still keep
eating it hang in there yeah it'll be
fine
I'll get me until I'd exactly yeah
that's a good 20 when I was a kid eyes
the last yeah they told me when I was a
boy eat that cabbage and you'll grow
breasts and I did you play in Vampire
Academy you play a very sexy
headmistress and this is a role that
they initially the role called for sort
of an old you know like an old sort of
witch like woman and they went a
completely different way and cast yeah
because in the book so of course it's
based on the books that we shall need
wrote and in the books the headmistress
is described as this horrible old very
dry tall lady with the big nose and my
hair and and I thought Oh perfect great
casting outside so and but I guess yeah
they decided when I got there they
started trying on all these sexy clothes
and and I think I'm the only character
who they modified from from the book I
think it went for the sexy option I
think it was a wise choice on their part
we have actually a still here of you in
your in your head miss oh yeah I
remember that moment it's just yes this
is how I was biting this poor guy it was
a next rose this young boy who got there
he was lying on the table yeah poor poor
boy poor guy yeah poor guy I was
supposed and I was crawling over him on
my fours and I was and he was looking at
me and I said don't worry I'm not gonna
bite you for real I knew you said uh-huh
and I don't know and I didn't buy yeah
but I'm gonna feel bad guy for a long
like not really biting him because I
wasn't going to it was more like kissing
his neck so I thought what is he
thinking I wonder what he's thinking
while I'm doing I'll tell you later what
he was there you get it Chuck how do you
get a job like that right I never I was
always like stop boy I know maybe you
can apply for you know to be an extra
yes I would do that in a second you'd
have to put in a good word for me
absolutely that meant no you're in you
looked away and Donna went absolutely we
have a clip here from Vampire Academy
anything we need to know for this the
clip yeah enjoy
well yeah enjoy and had mrs. Carreras is
a very mean lady she hates kids hate she
can't stand them I think she'd like to
torture them and and vote off and let's
take a look at this clip from Vampire
Academy you Hathaway a dumb pure girl
cut off from the community out in
civilian streets without it dying huh
blood Horace such an ugly term but I'm
sure Maroney meant on business trips
would pay a lot they especially sweet
days that mrs. Kyra they have the bond
my brief observation period Rose could
tell what Lisa was thinking or feeling
sometimes without being at the same
place what a rare and wonderful gift
this doesn't take away from the fact
that Rose Hathaway is wild dangerous
insubordinate Imbolc right here folks
right here I still want to go to that
school
[Applause]